[Music]
oh it's time we're still grilling up
some fun here on good day for National
grilling month the Nevada Barbecue
association helping us with some pork
tips this morning how to keep it moist
and juicy with a little extra Flair
all right we are here we are talking all
things grilling barbecuing whatever have
you and one of the main things that
you're going to want to throw on the
grill is some really awesome pork
product right so Christy van over
joining me here from girls can grow and
we're talking about this beautiful
um bacon lettuce if you will yeah so
this is going to be a pork on pork kind
of double pork here so we've got some
bacon and we've got a pork tenderloin
that I've already seasoned up with some
mustard and some of my pork rub and to
make this bacon weed you're just going
to take strips of bacon and same thing
like you would do with a pie a pie crust
if you do a lattice crust you're just
every other one you'll pull back
to put your piece of bacon in here
and then wow that's beautiful once
you've got that then you can set your
pork loin on here and we're gonna
actually use this
just
roll it up and this is uh parchment
paper parchment paper you could use wax
paper you could use foil even it doesn't
have to be anything fancy next is secure
it with toothpicks and pop it on the
grill bacon has to be crispy and not
floppy but the meat itself on the inside
has to be moist how do you do that yeah
so the secret to that is starting out
cooking it slowly so at 250 degrees with
an indirect heat so it's not right over
the fire not right over the Flames so
it's slowly going to be cooking the meat
at the same time that bacon is going to
start to render but it won't get fully
crispy until the very end so when your
pork has been on for about 90 minutes
then you crank the heat up the Bacon's
already pretty rendered the pork's
almost done and then it'll start to get
crispy and for those using a gas grill
you can still get that smoked flavor you
can add smoke to gas grills by just
putting some wood chips in a foil pouch
we're just adding a little bit of sauce
and then close your smoker back up or
your grill back up and then that's going
to help it get crispy how long is that
in there for you know about 15-20
minutes final step check the temperature
you want to cook it only to 145 degrees
internal temperature and that's what's
going to keep it really juicy and enjoy
oh and you will for events and
information about joining the Nevada
Barbecue association it's all posted at
8newsnow.com they do all kinds of like
competitions and educational classes
where she's talking about pork the whole
time as it's running we're talking about
cooking salmon we are all over there
stay tuned that's coming up too